so in past interviews that we've had
together and we've had many over the
years I have asked you repeatedly about
what you think about Joe Biden's
cognitive State I've asked you about is
he up to the job physically mentally you
have been very reluctant to go there
um I'm not reluctant to me does everyone
agree with me that this guy's
cognitively not there I doubt he knows
what day of the week it is today that's
how that's how bad I think it's gotten
for him
why are you reluctant to call that out
well I don't know if I'm supposed to say
this I actually called Sean and I asked
Sean not to joke about it I was joking
because he used to joke about it and I
said honestly I don't think it looks
good for you or for anybody if you to
joke about it because it's a serious
problem I was talking about sippy cup
and warm milky at night and
bedtime stories yeah so I said uh I just
don't think it's good for anybody and
you know it's uh not appropriate you can
speak about it if you want but you I
don't think you should joke about it and
you really didn't after that well now I
realize how serious it is I mean
especially we'll get into foreign policy
and you know with China Russia and Iran
forming I'm calling it a new axis of
Evil yeah I'm very very concerned that
he's abdicated our role in the world
stage let me let me I do say this I
think it's the most serious time in the
most dangerous time right now in the
history of our country we have nuclear
weapons on lots of different areas we
have Russia we have North Korea we have
Iran is going to soon have one that
should have never happened I had that
set up we would have made that deal
within a week after the election and
they would have never had a nuclear
weapon but nobody picked it up because I
terminated the Iran nuclear deal but
this is the most dangerous time in the
history of our country because of the
power of the weaponry and we have
somebody that doesn't understand what's
happening and it's a very dangerous
thing it's a very bad thing uh I mean
some really bad things if you would see
and I got to see it if you would see the
power of what we're talking about this
is an army tanks going back and forth
shooting at each other this is something
that's a whole different place this is
annihilation of the world literally the
power is so
so horrible and I was actually working
on something with Putin where we start
getting rid of nuclear weapons it's just
too powerful and you know all of a
sudden people are talking about nuclear
weapons all the time I wouldn't let
people talk about it I had somebody come
down from MIT I was talking about that
my uncle was a great Professor for many
years at MIT and I had somebody come
down and I said what would you say like
during the debate about nuclear weapons
he looked at me said sir
don't talk about them I said why he said
there's nothing you can say it's so
powerful it's so extraordinary the best
thing you can do is not talk about them
now they're talking about them all the
time that's all they talk about uh in
fact I guess Putin announced the other
day he's moving nuclear weapons to
Belarus
so this is a very dangerous time for our
country but it's a very dangerous time
for the whole world hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else